-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Happy Friday, everyone.
This is very exciting.
Tomorrow on NBC
is the 147 Kentucky Derby.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yep, the big race will feature
a bunch of three-year-olds
running around
while people just watch
and get drunk.
[ Laughter ]
It's like the sports version
of Zoom Kindergarten.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
The current derby favorite
is Essential Quality, yeah.
But there's an interesting horse
named Soup and Sandwich...
[ Laughter ]
...that's owned by the heiress
to Campbell's Soup...
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
...and it's rumored that,
if the horse loses,
he'll be...
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh!
-...fed some hay and say,
"Let's get 'em next year."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Put out to stud, yeah.
-Well, guys, yesterday
President Biden
held a rally in Georgia and,
at the end of his speech,
he invited
a couple of senators
to join him onstage,
but he had a little trouble
finding his mask to put back on.
[ Laughter ]
Watch him. Yeah, watch this.
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-Looking for my mask.
I'm in trouble.
-♪ I finally found you ♪
♪ Yes, that one ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
Right now,
the Pentagon's like, "Uh,
maybe we should give
the nuclear codes to Jill.
Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
You could practically hear
Jill thinking,
"If I have to go over there
and it's in this man's pocket...
[ Laughter ]
I'm telling you.
Joe, check your pocket."
Honestly, he's never been
more relatable
to every mask-wearing American
than at that very moment.
You're like,
"You've got to be kidding me.
I've been wearing
this dumb thing all day.
Drive me nuts.
This one was a tight,
uncomfortable one, too.
Where is it?"
I like how Biden timed
finding the mask
to the lyrics of the song.
Did you see that?
That's not bad.
Can we see that again?
-♪ I finally found you ♪
-Hey-oh!
-♪ Yes, that one ♪
-Like --
♪ I finally found you ♪
[ Laughter ]
Then, he should've
Moonwalked out.
Yeah, or did the Worm
or something.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
Nailed it.
Meanwhile, in South Carolina,
former Vice President Mike Pence
gave his first speech
since leaving the White House
and a lot of people think
it was the start
of his campaign for 2024.
[ Laughter ]
Pence actually has a great
chance to unite the country
'cause both Biden and Trump
voters can't stand him.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
See? Already.
-Took a while.
-Happening already.
-Yeah. Took a while.
-But listen to this.
This is very interesting.
I heard that,
during Pence's speech,
only 55 people watched
on Facebook Live.
[ Ohhs and laughter ]
Fifty-five.
Not million
or 55,000.
-Ugh!
-Fifty-five people.
[ Laughter ]
He's the only person
whose virtual events
have a 10% capacity.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Fifty-five people.
Some news from overseas --
today, Russia announced
that they produced
the world's first
COVID vaccine for animals...
[ Audience awws ]
...which means, pretty soon,
we'll have to deal
with animals posting
their vaccination cards
on social media.
[ Laughter ]
When the news broke,
Russian scientists were like --
[ Russian accent ]
Relax, relax.
We test on people, first.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm sure Russia's
animal vaccine is safe.
They actually gave it
to one of the horses
in the Kentucky Derby.
It's the number 6 horse,
Borscht or Sandwich.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Come on!
-Wow.
-Come on. You got to do it.
-Alright.
-You got to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Borscht or Sandwich.
Get this -- I saw that
Pope Francis just issued a law
that says Vatican employees
can't accept
any work-related gifts
more than $49.
[ Laughter ]
When asked why
he issued the law,
Pope Francis said --
[ As Francis ]
Because it's funny.
[ Laughter ]
The news really stunned
Vatican employees,
especially when the Pope
left the room on a hoverboard.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
no more gifts over $49.
And, now that the Church
has settled that issue,
there are officially
no more scandals.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some business news --
I saw that Lay's is releasing
new potato chips
that are dusted
with Cool Ranch Doritos
flavoring.
[ Ohhs and laughter ]
They've even got
a great name for them --
Cool Ranch Doritos.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, I saw that a man
in the Philippines holds
an interesting world record.
Watch this.
-This guy, in the Philippines,
Percival Lugue,
started collecting toys
that came in fast food meals
when he was five.
Fifty years later,
he's got about 20,000 of them.
-It's like he's living
inside the world's biggest
claw machine.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, that guy's family
hasn't had a happy meal
in 50 years.
"Clean it up!"
Also, we're planning
something really fun
in honor of Mother's Day.
We're going to team up
with our friends at Samsung
to celebrate some
amazing moms out there,
epic moms that have gone
above and beyond this past year.
We're going to do something
very special
every single night next week,
so be sure to tune in for that.
It's going to be a fun surprise.
[ Cheering and applause ]